[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y como cada
semana hablaremos de los derechos de las
mujeres el 1º de diciembre se conmemora
el día mundial de respuesta al vih hace
40 años se reportaron los primeros casos
de una enfermedad que hoy padecen casi
38 millones de personas en el mundo y
que implica un trabajo constante contra
la discriminación por eso en este
programa vamos a poner en nuestra parte
y nos vamos a enfocar en el reporte de
la comunidad internacional de mujeres
viviendo con vih/sida que da cuenta de
la perspectiva de mujeres jóvenes con el
virus en argentina chile honduras y
nicaragua
el mundo está lejos de cumplir la meta
de la onu de acabar con el sida para
2030 en 2020 había 37.7 millones de
personas viviendo con vih incluidas 10.2
millones sin tratamiento
hubo 1.5 millones de nuevos casos y 680
mil muertes relacionadas la mayor
prevalencia de esta epidemia está en
áfrica y en asia entre los obstáculos
para compartir la crisis destacan
desigualdades estructurales que bloquean
las funciones comprobadas para la
prevención y el tratamiento del vih y
cuando se habla de desigualdad las
mujeres son transversales a las crisis
lo evidencia del reporte desde la
perspectiva de mujeres jóvenes con vih
enfocado en países de américa latina
el estudio evalúa las vivencias de
ciudadanos en argentina chile nicaragua
y honduras
y concluyó ok en argentina se destacan
el acceso universal al tratamiento un
marco jurídico amplio en derechos
sexuales y reproductivos
la educación sexual integral en la
mayoría de los centros educativos y las
acciones para la detección precoz de
embarazadas con vih
pero la falta de adhesión a tratamientos
es un fenómeno que se mantiene por la
exclusión social y la pobreza contextos
de vulnerabilidad social que hacen que
el tratamiento no sea una prioridad el
auto estigma de mujeres jóvenes que un
84 por ciento de las veces temen revelar
su estado
en chile los centros de infectología
están colapsados debido a la pandemia
faltan datos de mujeres con vih
especialmente cuando son jóvenes los
centros de salud sexual y reproductiva
funcionan con menor intensidad la
depresión y los intentos de suicidio son
comunes en nicaragua la discriminación
familiar es la causa número uno de
violación de la confidencialidad en el
diagnóstico de mujeres jóvenes el
personal médico no es tolerante o
empático cuando se brinda el diagnóstico
las jóvenes se sienten insatisfechos con
la atención en salud y honduras es el
país con menos información accesible
sobre mujeres jóvenes y vih y es el país
con menos acceso a los servicios de
salud además en general hay una brecha
en la lucha contra el vih en américa
latina porque los estudios son limitados
en enfoque de género y en el foc etario
para la conversaciones sobre el tema
está en ella soy arely cano ella es
secretaria regionales de la comunidad
internacional de mujeres viviendo con
vih/sida y de c&w latina es activista
por los derechos de las personas que
viven con vih arely bienvenida a ellas
hoy y cuáles son las barreras más
importantes que impiden que los
servicios de prevención y tratamiento
lleguen a quienes más lo necesitan
las barreras más importantes que hemos
evidenciado a través de las
investigaciones de estudio tienen que
ver con las desigualdades no la falta de
una atención integral al atender el vih
pero sobre todo el estigma la
discriminación y la falta de compromiso
de los estados de no crear las
condiciones
importantes para atender la respuesta al
vih no solamente a la población que
afectada por vih sino también a la
población
que no tiene vih mire a 140 años después
es muy común en la llamada transmisión
vertical porque sigue sucediendo si es
algo completamente evitable porque tiene
que ver con las condiciones que deben de
crear los gobiernos los estados los
sistemas de salud en crear información
en empoderar no sobre
es transmisión vertical sobre el vih
lado de mes y la ups ha dejado verdad
dentro de sus políticas la importancia
de crear las condiciones para toda mujer
embarazada y evitar con una transmisión
de la madre al hijo esto significa que
si las mujeres que tienen un diagnóstico
de vih tienen un tratamiento oportuno de
tomar su tratamiento antirretroviral y
un control sobre el embarazo evita
verdad un 97% de no transmitir el virus
del vih durante el embarazo y al nacer
su bebé al mismo tiempo también la ong
se ha venido discutiendo a nivel
regional y mundial también sobre el tema
de la lactancia que si la madre también
tienen una carga viral indetectable con
su tratamiento éstas podrían tener ese
derecho no y también de dar de mamar sin
embargo todavía esos son temas de
discusión y de políticas en los países
para poder dar este tipo de respuesta
también hemos estado haciendo mucha
demanda en qué
evitemos lo menos posibles las cesáreas
en mujeres con vih la mayoría de
nuestros países
principalmente verdad en latinoamérica
se siguen haciendo las cesáreas en
mujeres cuando con vih sin embargo esto
se podría evitar
garantizando la atención integral
durante el embarazo para no tener
transmisión de vih evitar una cesárea
significa
garantizar el cuido sobre
su recuperación después del embarazo que
cada una después de tener su bebé bueno
y hablando de esto la falta de
informaciones sobre salud sexual y
reproductiva cómo es que afecta
precisamente las cifras de vih
si afecta porque mientras no haya
información y educación sexual
el estigma el miedo a hacerse la prueba
del vih
va a permitir a no tener datos claros
sobre cómo está afectando
el vih en nuestros países y esto permite
también a no tener clara cómo va la
pandemia y cómo responder a la misma en
nuestro país nosotros le llamamos
mientras menos información tengamos más
estigma más discriminación y violencia
ayudamos a tener una epidemia oculta
bueno y otro tema además ella hablando
de lo médico es el desafío de la
adherencia a los antirretrovirales
porque se interrumpe su flujo
tiene que ver con varios varios desafíos
uno que es por ejemplo ahora mismo que
tuvimos la pandemia del cob y para ir a
retirar los tratamientos
antiretrovirales que habían toque de
queda
habían
restricciones para accesar a los
sistemas de salud y sobre todo también
con el tema de fraccionamiento de los
medicamentos cuando hablamos de
fraccionamientos hablamos que en varios
sistemas de salud colapsaron en términos
de que no había
tratamientos antiretrovirales y esto
tenía que ver con logística con
planificación de compras los sistemas de
salud no habían planificado
lo suficiente en compras de tratamiento
y hubieron desabastecimiento en algunos
en algunos países como ecuador como el
perú donde las organizaciones tuvieron
que hacer activismo fuerte para que no
hubiera ese abastecimiento y buscar
formas de llevar los medicamentos
antiretrovirales a las compañeras
en nuestros países como centroamérica el
tema de detener el miedo a contraer el
cob y también fue otro factor sin
embargo en lo cotidiano y en lo normal
en nuestras vidas el fallar del
medicamento puede tener una resistencia
a los mismos y cambiar de esquema porque
ya en el primer esquema ya no puede ser
efectivo y lo otro es son las
condiciones sociales si las personas no
tienen para alimentarse no tienen un
entorno seguro en el hogar porque la
familia no quieren que la familia se dé
cuenta que toma x tratamiento y esto
mucho menos para el vih pues estos dejan
de tomar esto significa tener un
deterioro de vida incluso hasta perder
su vida en un trayecto verdad de meses
bueno arely y ya para el cierre
finalmente que tan cerca estamos de una
cura se cumplirá la meta de erradicación
es para el 2030
totalmente que no sea estamos viendo a
40 años se cumplieron en demandas no
también desde que salió el primer caso
de vih a nivel mundial
activismo internacional nacional
regional y todavía los esfuerzos no han
sido suficiente si bien es cierto hemos
pasado en medicamentos que se tomaban
hasta siete pastillas 8 pastillas a 1 a
una pastilla de 2 fácil en algunos
países sin embargo pues sigue siendo
todavía es desalentador el tema de tener
una vacuna desde nuestra organización
seguimos en campaña todos los tiempos
demandar tener la cura y deseamos que
los jóvenes tienen mucha esperanza de
que pronto podamos no esperemos llegar a
unos 40 años más para realmente contar
con la vacuna los medicamentos han sido
efectivos han ayudado mucho
y esté salvado muchas vidas pero sin
embargo seguimos teniendo casos de vih
seguimos teniendo personas que están
muriendo a causa vih seguimos teniendo
niños que están naciendo con vih esto
significa que todavía hace falta mucho
que hacer y tenemos una esperanza una
esperanza que que nos ha puesto la
pandemia del cob y que hay que seguir
demandando hay que seguir haciendo
incidencia política para que los
gobiernos se comprometan a
los laboratorios todo lo que tiene que
ver con investigación a ponernos este
compromiso a funcionar y que pronto
podamos tener la cura para el vih y que
si sea para él y gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y por el informe
también dice wv la tina sigan con
nosotros en france 24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]